welcome to another cold fusion video
i'm going to start this video off with a
quote henry ford once said
it is well enough that the people of the
nation do not understand our banking and
monetary system
for if they did i believe there would be
a revolution before tomorrow morning
i quote this because it encapsulates the
fact that the contents of this video
may be unsettling compared to the videos
that i normally make
i still feel compelled to make this
video because i've been exploring the
financial world for the last four years
and it's definitely given me a more
complete view of the world
i want to share some of what i've come
across with you guys
i'm also going to do a video about
crypto currencies like bitcoin in the
future
and to understand why bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies may continue to rise
it's critical that you understand the
contents of this video i hope that you
find this topic interesting and that
inspires you to do your own research
afterwards now with that said let's
begin
anybody
[Music]
so who controls all of our money it's a
simple question
we all know that you and i don't control
it our employees don't control it
the companies that they work for don't
control it so who does
where does it even come from in the
first place i'll give you a hint
money does not come from the government
it's a seemingly obvious question that's
never asked or taught in school for some
reason
unfortunately most people's lives are
basically dedicated to money
it's all people ever worry about or talk
about
we go to school to learn basically how
to go to university
to learn the skills to get a good job so
that we can trade hours of our lives
all for this thing called money so why
wouldn't you want to know where money
comes from
and who issues it today in this very
special video
you're about to find out the answer to
the question of who controls all of our
money
people today can tell something isn't
quite right with our financial system
but they just can't put their finger on
it some people think it's the failure of
government
others think that it's the failure of
capitalism itself
this video should clarify a few things
[Music]
the year is 1694 and england had just
suffered through 50 years of war
exhausted the english government needed
loans to fund their political means
brainchild of scottish banker william
patterson it was decided that a
privately owned bank that could issue
the money to the government out of thin
air was to be the solution
this was the very first modern central
banking system in the world
central banking is more influential than
laws governments
and politicians but strangely not the
focus of the general public
fast forward to the early 20th century
and after two failed attempts
a group of bankers wanted to put a
central bank in the united states of
america
it was december of 1910 and senator
nelson aldridge ordered a private train
car in new york with six others
the six were not to be spotted by any
news reporters to avoid questions
their destination jekyll island off the
coast of georgia
the meeting went for nine days and from
that they created the federal reserve
system
this is all documented and a matter of
public record
some of them went on to write about the
meetings in their personal biographies
here's a quote from frank van der lib
president of the national city bank of
new york
february 9 1935 in the saturday evening
post
i was as secretive indeed as furtive as
any conspirator discovery we knew simply
must not happen
or else all our time and effort would be
wasted
if it were to be exposed that our
particular group had got together and
written a banking bill that bill would
have no chance whatever
a passage by congress the sixth man that
nelson eldridge brought together
included the head of banks branches of
government such as the treasury
and some of the richest people on earth
at the time
to give you an idea of how rich they
were in 1910
these six men represented a quarter of
the world's worth
the bankers told the american public
that the purpose of the system was to
stabilize the economy and to stop the
grip of the wall street banks over
america
the problem was the guys that wrote the
bill were the very same people they said
they'd stop
if they succeeded it would give a small
group of men the ability to create money
from nothing
and loan it to the american government
with interest
so why was it done in secret because the
american people didn't want a central
bank
back then unlike today people knew what
central banks were and understood them
very well
everywhere a central bank went there'll
be wealth inequality
wild swings between economic booms and
bus and after each bust
those at the top of society mysteriously
came out richer while everyone else got
poorer
europe was the running example of this
at the time
the federal reserve was originally
drafted as the eldridge bill but when it
came into congress they recognized
senator aldridge's name
and smelt a rat the bankers needed
better cover
they decided to send 2 million their
friends to carry the bill to quell the
suspicions of congress and renamed it
the federal reserve act
next in a textbook lesson of the seat
the bankers set out to fool the american
people
through disinformation in the newspapers
of the day
the bankers screamed and protested
against the new federal reserve bill it
would ruin the banks they exclaimed
the average person read the protesting
articles of the bankers and thought to
themselves
if the bankers hate it it must be good
and then they ended up unknowingly
supporting a trojan horse
the bankers also fooled congress by
putting clauses in the bill that limited
their power only to remove them
once the bill was passed a double head
fake of the public and congress was all
it took
the bill was passed on december 23 1913
while most of congress was out on
holiday
and with that a small group had complete
monopoly over the issuing and creation
of american money
today the federal reserve is the most
powerful entity in the united states
and they're not ashamed to admit it
either he is former fed chairman
alan greenspan what should be the proper
relationship between the chairman of the
fed and a president of the united states
well first of all the federal reserve is
an independent agency and that means
basically that
there is no other agency of government
which can overrule actions that we take
what the relationships are uh don't
frankly matter
in addition to this it seems that the
fed can't even be touched by
investigating parties
so i'm asking you if your agency has in
fact according to bloomberg
extended nine trillion dollars in credit
which by the way works out that thirty
thousand dollars for every single man
woman and child in this country i'd like
to know if you're not responsible for
investigating that
who is
[Music]
we actually we have responsibility for
the federal reserve's programs and
operations audits
to conduct audits and investigations in
that area um
in terms of who's responsible for
investigating
would you mind repeating the question
one more time mr chairman my time is up
but i have to tell you honestly i am
shocked to find out
that nobody at the federal reserve
including inspector general is keeping
track of this
so what does all of this have to do with
me you might be asking
i don't even live in the us well two
reasons
number one the central banking model
from the bank of england
and the united states has now been put
in all countries
and even consolidated power in parts of
europe as the european central bank
or ecb this unites separate countries
under one
economic policy the only places in the
world that don't have central banks
are north korea iran and cuba in 2000
this list suspiciously included
afghanistan
iraq and libya and number two
since the end of world war ii the us
dollar has been the reserve currency of
the world
this means that all central banks hold
us dollars in their reserves
in other words all other currencies are
backed by the us dollar
this directly links your country to the
federal reserve's monetary policy in
america
more on this later when the post-world
war ii monetary system called the
bretton wood system was created
all us dollars were backed by and
exchangeable for gold
a byproduct of this was that currencies
used to be very stable in relation to
each other
before that all the countries the
exchange rates were fixed
and year after year you could predict
what prices were going to be
you could start a business elsewhere
know if you were you know you could
calculate
profits business was much much easier
before floating exchange rates
unfortunately in 1971 due to a falling
u.s dollar
international capital flows into gold
and the funding of the vietnam war
president nixon took the us dollar off
the gold standard
i have directed secretary connelly to
suspend temporarily the convertibility
of the dollar
into gold or other reserve assets
now the dollar was floating and backed
by nothing and has been
ever since okay so let's think a little
if the us dollar is backed by nothing
but the worlds reserved are backed by
the us dollar
intrinsically since 1971 doesn't this
mean that all currencies
are now backed by nothing tangible only
trust in the american government
well this is correct money backed by
nothing
is known as fiat currency fiat in latin
means let it be done in other words the
government says
it is money so it is
a consequence to having money back by
nothing is that whenever the federal
reserve creates money it dilutes the
currency supply of all other nations
because their reserves are backed by the
us dollar
all countries reserves are worth less
each time money is created
in the past few years the federal
reserve has printed trillions of dollars
and countries like russia and china have
noticed this
as a reaction to the money printing
these countries have been selling u.s
dollar reserves and buying gold over the
same period
but wait a second some of you clever
thinkers out there may have asked
yourself
if every currency on earth is backed by
nothing how am i able to pay for things
well as it turns out the whole economic
system today is running because it's
backed by
faith faith that you can exchange your
unit of currency for goods or services
in a way part of that faith comes from
the fact that not many people
actually know where money comes from
we're about to find that out in this
video
[Music]
a central bank is essentially the entity
that manages a nation's money supply and
it can loan money to the government with
interest
in the united states and most other
countries it works like this
when the government needs more money
than they receive from taxes they ask
the treasury department for money
the treasury then receives an iou or
bond from the government
the treasury through the banks gives
this iou to the federal reserve
the fed then writes a check for this iau
and hands it to the banks
at this exchange at the banks money is
created and it can be used to pay
government bills
so hang on where does the fed get the
money to be able to write this check
they get this money from nowhere they
literally just invent it
here's a quote from the boston federal
reserve quote when you or i write a
check
there must be sufficient funds in our
account to cover the check
but when the federal reserve writes a
check there is no bank deposit on which
that check is drawn
when the federal reserve writes a check
it is creating money
end quote so in essence they're writing
a check and creating money
from an account that has no money in it
the money the federal reserve creates
can be used as legal tender to buy
things and eventually makes its way into
the real economy
if you and i did that would go to jail
for fraud but they can do it because
they invented the system
this is the same system used throughout
the world today
another part of this money creation
happens at the commercial bank side
every time you take out a loan to buy a
house car or tv
banks create money out of nowhere to
give you this loan and you still have to
pay interest on it
and don't just believe me when i say
that hear it for yourself from the
horse's mouth
the people running the system graeme
towers former governor of the central
bank of canada
states quote each and every time a bank
makes a loan
new credit is created new deposits brand
new money
end quote paul tucker deputy
governor of the bank of england quote
banks extend credit by simply increasing
the borrowing customers current account
end quote so what they're basically
saying is that each time the bank makes
a loan
the bank doesn't use other people's
deposit and money and give it to you
it creates new money in modern times
this means typing digits into a computer
97 of all money is digitally created
like this
only 3 is the physical cash and coins
that we carry another crazy thing that
commercial banks can do
is lend out 10 times more money than
they actually have in reserves
this is called fractional reserve
lending so who wrote this ridiculous
system into law
for the united states it was part of the
federal reserve system drafted in 1913
and again this is the same system used
throughout the world
so what's the issue why should i even
care
well there's consequences when more
loans are given out
more money is created and the rest of
the money in circulation is worth less
and less
as the years go on this is known as
inflation
in a way inflation is basically a tax
that we all pay for the fraud of money
printing
easy money now in exchange for tax on
our future generations
it's also why in 1950 a house used to
cost seven thousand dollars and a car
two thousand dollars obviously this is
no longer the same today
things will always keep getting more
expensive as long as this system is in
place
this was actually kind of okay because
wages grew in relation to inflation
until about 2008
why this stopped happening is a story
for another day
so things are already pretty crazy but
they get even crazier
the more you look into it the stranger
things become
so remember how we're talking about how
central banks and commercial banks can
create money out of nothing
this procedure actually does create
something it creates debt
let me explain when you take out a loan
it's written down as an asset in the
bank as a negative form
kind of like a negative value of money
or otherwise known as debt
under this system debt is actually money
and again don't just listen to me
mariner echols former governor of the
federal reserve states
quote if there were no debts in our
money system
there wouldn't be any money so in
essence
instead of gold being the backbone of
our economy it's now
debt the system we're under now
is sometimes referred to as the
debt-based monetary system
it requires that debt always grows
countries and people
must become deeper in debt so that
there's more money in the system
because remember debt is money
if people and government stop borrowing
money and pay back loans
the debt doesn't grow the money supply
shrinks and the system falters
it truly is bizarre but we all live in
this system each and every day
[Music]
the federal reserve and other central
banks control money by adjusting its
supply
and how much it costs to borrow money
otherwise known as the interest rate
with these tools and as a consequence of
human group psychology
central banks can create booms and busts
in the economy at will
and also distort and derail an economy
by messing with it
let's take a quick case study in the
year 2000
federal reserve chairman alan greenspan
cut interest rates to one percent
he did this to try and fight off a
recession from the dot-com bubble and
encourage people to borrow money
when interest rates are low if you're
borrowing money you save a whole lot on
repaying mortgages
since the 1 interest rate hadn't been
seen at the time since the 1950s
it was a pretty good deal greenspan's
idea was that he could create a wealth
effect
people would start to buy houses the
prices would go up
and the people would feel wealthier and
spend more money in the economy
and stimulate it greenspan sure
succeeded in getting people to borrow
money to buy houses
but they borrowed too much and the
result was the 2008 housing bubble
this is a prime example of what can go
wrong when central banks mess with an
economy
yes corrupt bankers have a lot to answer
for in their role in the 2008 crisis
but the fed has a far bigger long-term
impact
even crazier things are happening in
japan their central bank is buying so
many stocks that they were the number
one buyer of japanese stocks in 2016
so they have part ownership of companies
with money that they created from
nothing
so in essence it is the central banks
that control our economy
and the central and commercial banking
system together that control
all of our money the difference is
central banks can create money at will
while commercial banks need loans to
create money
[Music]
to give you an idea of people's views of
central banking when people actually
knew what central banks were
here's a couple of examples in 1881
then president of the united states
james garfield states
quote whoever controls the volume of
money in any country
is absolute master of all industry and
commerce and when you realize that the
entire system
is very easily controlled one way or
another by a few powerful men at the top
you will not have to be told how periods
of inflation and depression originate
end quote benjamin franklin in his
autobiography stated that the prime
reason for the american war of
independence
was a battle over who actually
controlled and issued the money of the
new colonies
moving on to more modern times noble
prize-winning economist milton friedman
states
quote the federal reserve definitely
caused the great depression by
contracting the amount of currency in
circulation by one-third
from 1929 to 1933 end quote
so with all this being said some would
argue that central banks are not
inherently
a bad thing they just need to be part of
the government and not privately owned
the government should be able to issue
its own money for the benefit of the
people and shouldn't have to pay a
massive interest on its own debt
this was tried at least once in the
united states by president lincoln
he stated this the government should
create
issue and circulate all the currency and
credit needed to satisfy the spending
power of the government
and the buying power of consumers by the
adoption of these principles the
taxpayers will be saved immense
sums of interest money will cease to be
mastered become the servant
of humanity abraham lincoln then issued
his own government money
it was called the greenback no further
comments on that story
[Music]
so i think we'll end the video there
there's so much more that i could cover
about what central banking decisions led
to what revolutions around the world
pretty much when you look at it all
revolutions and all wars when you dig
through everything
it all boils down to money i could also
have talked about the new global
movement of those who are rejecting the
debt-based economic system
people are starting to move their
currency into gold silver and crypto
currencies
like bitcoin so there is a light at the
end of the tunnel
that's a whole other story for another
day anyways if you've watched the whole
way through this video congratulations
you're one of the few who have found out
the hidden truths about who controls all
of our money
i think i've only met about four people
in real life that have been aware of the
debt-based economic system
it's strangely unknown but is as true as
anything i even showed you all the
quotes of the bankers and the former
heads of the federal reserve telling you
from their own now's how the system
actually works
if this is your first time hearing all
of this i encourage you as i said before
to do your own research
and then you'll start to see the bigger
picture and the world today will make a
whole lot more sense
if you want some good starting resources
i recommend mike maloney's hidden
secrets and money series it's here on
youtube and i'll leave a link below
mike is a very knowledgeable guy and
i've had some great long conversations
with him about the economy
if you're into reading and you want to
know more about the history of the
federal reserve
i recommend the book by geodude griffin
the creature from jekyll island
so anyway i think i'll stop talking now
thanks for watching this video this has
been to go go
you all been watching cold fusion feel
free to subscribe to this channel if
you're new this isn't the stuff i
normally make but i think you'll like
the other stuff anyway
i really hope you learned something from
this video and i'll see you again soon
for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion it's new thinking
you